[Music]
we're going to talk about today is
constraint satisfaction problems and
this comes from chapter three
of both classic computer science
problems in swift and also classic
computer science problems in python
both of these books are books for people
who either are a little bit rusty on
their computer science but have been
programming for several years or maybe
people who never had a computer science
education
and they're working as programmers or
doing programming as a hobby and they
want to get kind of a general survey of
several different computer science
topics i'll introduce myself a little
bit so my name is david kopeck i am the
author of class computer science
problems in swift and class computer
science problems in python as well as
dart for absolute beginners i work as an
assistant professor of computer science
at champlain college i teach a wide
variety of computer science courses and
i'm really excited to be with you and to
get a chance to
talk to you a little bit about
constraint satisfaction problems in the
books in general so
uh what i thought i'd do is i would have
both a combination of
the code that we'll kind of go through
from the book and i also would actually
show you some diagrams from the book
directly that are relevant to what we'll
be talking about so what is a constraint
satisfaction problem well a constraint
satisfaction problem is what it sounds
like something where you have a problem
that has some constraints but what is a
constraint so before we even talk about
that like title of the
of the chapter constraint satisfaction
problems let's talk about the general
idea of variables and domains
so
a variable
is just like a variable in programming
it can be something that holds multiple
different values but at any one time
might be holding just one value
and we want to ideally set variables to
the right values to solve some kind of
problems
but what kind of values can we actually
set the variables to
well that's the purpose of domains so
domains tell us these are the possible
values for these variables
so i have an example up here uh this is
a type of problem that constraint
satisfaction problems are used a lot for
solving a scheduling problem
so we have some variables in this case
our variables are actually different
people and maybe the people who need to
make some meeting so mary jo and sue are
our variables
and the domain might be the times that
those variables are available for the
meeting so perhaps they're available
between 2 and 4 pm or something like
that
so
and then the constraints that's where
this actually becomes a constraint
satisfaction problem those are the
requirements between the variables that
need to be true
in order for the problem to be solved
so in this problem we have constraints
about who needs to be at the meeting
sue and mary need to be at the meeting
or joe can be at the meeting so we could
have mary and joe uh or we could have
mer we could just have joe
or we could have we need to have sue and
mary sorry we need to have sue and mary
and we could have joe with them or we
could not have joe but one constraint is
we must have sue and mary and the other
constraint is we may or may not have joe
so
if we can find a way to find meeting
times in other words domains for all
three of these people
and we can satisfy that the right people
via those constraints can be at the
meeting then we can solve the problem so
this happens all the time i mean you
think about when you use like google
calendar or you use apple ical and
you're trying they don't call it ical
anymore right now it's apple calendar um
they and they're trying to figure out
different people's schedules and a time
that they next are all available they're
solving a constraint satisfaction
problem like this so this one is uh a
little more involved we're going to
solve some simpler ones over the next
few minutes but before we do that
let me show you the beginning of our
python code for
going through a constraint satisfaction
problem and then we'll go into some
specific constraint satisfaction
problems
so our python code um starts with
defining what a constraint is
so a cons and you'll notice i use type
hints throughout this and i'll just say
something about type ins you know um
type hints in my mind add clarity to
especially when you're reading code they
make it longer when you write code in
python but i think they add some clarity
when you're reading code but i will say
it was the most controversial decision i
made around the book was putting type
hints in everywhere
and some people love taipings some
people
really just find them a little
cluttering and they make the code a
little bit more verbose but i use type
hints throughout here if you're not
familiar with type hints you can
actually just read the code without the
type hints and it's basically
the standard python for you without the
type hints so anytime you see a colon
that's adding in a type hint but if you
just take out the colon it's just python
without the type-ins a constraint a
constraint is something between
variables right they're the
things that are constrained are the
variables so this constraint class is
really simple all it has to do is take a
list of variables
and then make sure that all of them are
satisfied but for a generic constraint a
constraint that isn't specific to a
certain kind of problem we don't know
what it means for that constraint to be
satisfied so if this was a scheduling
problem
that satisfaction might have to do with
that all the variables
certain of the variables are available
at that time but for other kinds of
problems there's going to be different
factors that go into whether or not the
constraint is satisfied so we're going
to end up overriding this method
satisfied in subclasses of constraint
that are implemented for our different
kinds of problems
okay
so that's our constraint then we have
the general structure for holding the
entire constraint satisfaction problem
together and we call that the class csp
and
csp is
[Music]
a generic class again
because we want to be able to work with
different types for both the variables
and the domains so
our variables might be strings or they
might be integers our domains might be
strings they might be integers they
might be something else altogether
so depending on the type of problem
we're going to have different kinds of
variables and constraints excuse me in
domains and this is going to differ
depending on the specifics of the
problem and so this is where you start
to see some
python type hints coming into play here
so this is in python type in saying that
v and d
could be any specific type we don't know
what type they are at the time that
we're defining the class but in the
future the user of this class is going
to specify some types for v and some
types for d and that type has to be the
same throughout the subclass so
variables will always be of some type
for some particular type of problem and
domains will always be of some type for
some particular type of problem so what
does the csp do though it gathers
together variables domains and
constraints
it's responsible for associating
variables with domains and asso and
responsible for ensuring that all of the
constraints are actually satisfied so
that's what this constructor is doing
it's just assembling variables domains
and constraints as dictionaries so that
we can look them up later on and then
when we want to add a constraint we
actually have a method here add
constraint and what it will do just is
do a sanity check and just make sure hey
this constraint is between certain
variables do those variables actually
exist in the problem
if the variables actually exist in the
problem
then we're good and we can add this
constraint in if it's not that means
there was something wrong in the
construction of the constraints that's
that's really just a sanity check there
um nothing nothing more sophisticated
going on
okay so so far we've just been doing
setup now we get into the real stuff
so consistent what's consistent
consistent looks to check
if
every
constraint for some particular
cons variable so remember different
constraints are going to be associated
with different variables so constraints
for some variable let's say it was our
scheduling problem let's say all the
constraints around joe so the different
constraints that limited joe's
applicability to a meeting
are all of those satisfied
if they are then that's good and that
means that we have a good solution so
far for the constraints for this
variable
if they're not satisfied we're actually
going to have to go back and try some
different domain values for this
variable to try to solve it and the way
that we're going to do that is through
what's called a backtracking search
which is actually our next method so
i'll go into that in a minute but i do
want to mention
look how nice it is to be storing
everything in dictionaries because we
can easily just look things up by the
variable right so we can just quickly
look up these are the constraints
associated with this variable
okay
so then this is the the most
sophisticated although it's not that
sophisticated um this is the most
sophisticated part of the constraint
satisfaction problem the backtracking
search this is the the real like meat of
it this is the the part that actually
does something so the backtracking
search is responsible for trying to find
domain values that can go in for each of
the variables that will satisfy all of
the constraints
so how does it work well every time we
do a backtracking search we have some
kind of assignment so those are
potential domain values for the
variables
and
if we have the same number of
assignments
as we have variables that means we've
actually assigned everything that means
that every variable has some assignments
so we've we've found a domain value that
fits in for every variable and that's a
great thing so in that case we're done
and we actually return the assignment
because we've successfully assigned
every variable to a domain value
however
most the time until we finish that won't
be true and so we just keep track of
here which variables don't yet have an
assignment so which variables have we
not yet found domain values for to go
into them that's what unassigned is here
and we use a little list comprehensive
comprehension in python here to to do
that
then how do we actually go and
do the search to see what domain values
might be applicable for this variable
well this is actually if it if you've
seen depth first search before the depth
first search algorithm before this is a
form of depth first search what we do is
we first look at the first unassigned
variable
we keep track of that in a in a variable
here a python variable now not a
constraint satisfaction variable
then we go through all the potential
domains for that variable so we're just
going to go through them one by one in
the original order that they were put
into
the domains
and for each of them
we create a new potential assignment
taking the old assignment because the
old assignment will have the domains for
all the previous variables and we add in
this one just one new variables
assignment and we add that to this new
what we call local assignment
and if it turns out that remember that
method we did consistent which checks
all the constraints if it turns out that
this new assignment combined with all of
the old ones together
is consistent so that means all the
constraints are satisfied
then we're good and that means this was
a good assignment
and in that case we do we call
backtracking search recursively and what
will happen is then let's go back to the
top here
the assignment will now become what was
the local assignment now with one more
variable successfully filled in with a
domain value for it
and that means that now we can move on
to yet one more
unassigned variable or if we're totally
done we'll just return the assignment so
it's actually a pretty simple recursive
depth first search going on here
if you're not familiar with depth first
search i could understand that this
would look pretty intimidating
but great news is a depth first search
is actually covered in chapter two of
the book so we cover depth first search
in chapter two of the book and then in
chapter three
in constraint satisfaction problems we
kind of assume that you have that
knowledge about depth first search but
basically depth first search uh let me
give you an idea about it as an analogy
in the real world so
if you had an onion and there was
something like
inside of your onion somewhere maybe
there was some insect crawling around
inside of it it's kind of a
nasty example but i'll do it anyway
there's some insect crawling inside of
your onion and you want to find it right
there's two main strategies you might
use there's breath for search where you
might kind of peel the onion back one
layer at a time looking for that insect
and then there's depth first search
where you might just kind of stick a
knife into the onion and you hope you
found it you just went really deep
really fast and you weren't doing it
super methodically you went and you
tried a bunch of values tried a bunch of
places to search for it and you didn't
quite find it so then you backtracked to
the last place you were and you stick
the knife in a little bit differently
and hope you found the um
the
insect that way it's not always the most
efficient way to do things and this is
not the most efficient way to
necessarily to solve a constraint
satisfaction problem but it is a
it certainly works and it's one that's
very simple to illustrate which is why
we use this this method in the in the
book in chapter three okay so now let's
use this framework to try to solve some
specific actual problems so this was all
just build up to be able to try to solve
a problem but let's try some actual
variables some actual domains and some
actual constraints
going to open back up the
the preview here of some of the problems
from the book and let's look at the
australian map coloring problem
so here's the problem we have the nation
of australia and australia has multiple
different regions i think some of them
are territories and some of them are
provinces but i'll just call all of them
regions
and what we want to do is we want to
color each of the different parts of
australia
with a different color
and we're going to have three different
colors that we can use we can use maybe
blue
green and red
so the question is can we make the
computer automatically color them for us
so us as human beings don't need to do
it not that this is like a very hard
problem to do as a human being in fact
if you try doing it yourself with a
blank map of australia you can probably
do it in just a few minutes but it's
often used as a first problem in
constraint satisfaction problem solving
education i guess or teaching
because it's so easy to think about and
reason about
so
if we think about this what are our
variables and what are our domains here
so the variables would be
each of the different regions
and we could think about them as just
strings in our program so they could be
strings like western australia the
string western australia could be one of
them that's that's a variable
northern territory could be a string
what are the domains the domains are
what colors we could fill in for those
variables so we have three different
colors here we have red green and blue
so the domain is actually going to be
the same for every variable because
western australia could be red green or
blue depending on how we solve the
problem south australia could be red
green or blue depending on how we solve
the problem
now what's the constraint well that's
where the problem actually gets
interesting the point of this is that we
don't want to have and i should have
maybe said it at the beginning we don't
want to have any of the two regions next
to each other
having the same color so we want to make
sure that every two regions next to each
other have a different color so we want
western australia to have a different
color from northern territory but we
also want western australia to have a
different color from south australia so
we want to make sure there's always
no two regions that border each other
are adjacent to each other that have the
same color so that's going to be our
constraint
so now that we have a constraint
satisfaction problem solving framework
how can we actually now codify the
problem and the constraints
so actually i think before we even look
at the constraint let's look at how we
codified the variables so my variables
here
are just a list of strings each string
representing one region of australia
the domains are just going to be strings
that represent the different colors so
the domains can be red green blue
and they can be red green or blue for
any of the regions and so we're just
going to go through all the variables
and assign the domains red green and
blue to all of them it was that easy now
that we have this framework in place it
was that simple to define variables and
constraints and we've actually just
defined almost the whole problem the
last part is the constraints
so the constraints are that we don't
want to have two regions next to each
other that have the same
color right
so before i go and we look at all this
code for adding all the constraints
let's look at how a constraint is
actually defined
so a map coloring constraint is a sub
of the constraint class that we looked
at earlier and remember that constraint
we said before was generic in that the
variables and the domains could be any
type but now in this problem we have
specific types we know that all the
variables are going to be python strings
they're going to be things like western
australia northern territory and we know
that the domains are also going to be
strings they're going to be things like
red green or blue
and so
when we end up subclassing constraint
here we can actually now fill in the
types and string is going to fill in for
the variable type and string is also
going to fill in for the domain type so
therefore a map color and constraint is
going to be a constraint between
variables with that are strings that
have domains that are strings and other
variables that are strings that have
domains that are strings
so when we initialize a new map coloring
constraint
what we want to provide it are the two
places so remember it's always going to
be between two adjacent regions of
australia so that's going to be places
like
northern australia and western australia
that's going to be places like or sorry
northern territory sorry if there's any
australians listening things like
northern territory in south australia
it's always two of them that we're
constraining so that's what place one
and place two are
and then how are they satisfied well
we wanna make sure that they don't have
the same
domain so they don't have the same color
how do we check that they don't have the
same color well it's this really simple
line here not equal to
how simple is that right we want to make
sure that red is not equal to green
right we want to make sure red is not
equal to blue blue is not equal to green
we want to just make sure that they're
not the same
the same string
you might wonder why is this first line
in here
well we can't even do a check if we
haven't yet assigned both of them so for
example if i've assigned a color for
western australia but i haven't yet
assigned a color for northern territory
then there's really no way for me to
actually check between the two of them
whether this the constraint is satisfied
so in that case i i just returned true
because i want to keep going until i
actually have some kind of
assignment for both of them
but once i have an assignment for both
them it's as simple as just checking
that it's not the same assignment so
it's really straightforward
then
here's the code for actually adding in
all the constraints now this part was
done manually right so there was no way
to automatically know it would have been
cool maybe if i'd used some machine
learning and read in the map file and it
automatically figured out that this
region is has this name and it's next to
this region that is this name but here
we just manually uh this is basically
our map this is us manually adding
constraints in for each of the adjacent
regions so we're adding in western
australia to northern territory
etc etc right victoria to new south
wales because they're next to each other
victoria to tasmania so any two that are
adjacent we need to have a constraint
between them so we just added in all
these constraints here
then we're just calling methods on what
we defined earlier remember earlier on
we defined the constraint satisfaction
class to have the backtracking search
method
we're just searching through and if we
found a solution we print out the
solution and if we didn't find a
solution we print out no solution found
so let me try running it let's see what
the results look like
so it colored them successfully so first
of all we know that because it didn't
just print out no solution found
and the solution is that western
australia should be red
northern territory should be green
south australia should be blue et cetera
et cetera et cetera and that is if you
look here that's actually what we
illustrated here in the um
in the diagram in the book was the
solution obviously
so okay you might be saying that seemed
like a lot of work to solve that problem
that seemed like you did a lot of setup
there a lot of preparation
to solve what looks like not that hard a
problem well
what i think is more interesting here is
how we can reuse that same framework now
to solve different kinds of problems so
let's solve two or three other problems
that look quite different from the map
coloring problem using the same exact
framework
and what i'll do for that is i will go
over to the next diagram so we can
illustrate the next problem
is called the eight queens problem
here's the challenge you have a chess
board
and what you wanna do is you wanna
actually place eight queens on the
chessboard so that none of them are
threatening each other or attacking each
other depending on what your parlance is
so this is an actual potential solution
here now for those that don't play chess
the way that queens work is they can
actually move both diagonally and they
can also move vertically and
horizontally across
columns and rows so they're the most
powerful piece in the game and they can
they can just glide across the board to
any square that's within a diagonal
that's not blocked by something within a
a row or a column so in this case if you
follow the diagonals let's say we follow
the queen on c7
if you follow the diagonals
or you follow the the row here or the
column you'll see there's no other queen
within
any of those places
so therefore this is a queen that um
[Music]
that is a good part of a solution to the
a queen's problem because it's not
threatening or attacking any other
queens so the question is can we place
all eight of them on the board without
any of them threatening or attacking any
other queens and there's actually more
than one solution to this problem so
there's there's actually many different
boards that have the queens in different
places that successfully solves a
problem but we just want to try to find
one solution can we just find one
solution to this to this problem
so we won't go back to csp because we
already solved that that's the great
thing right we already know what a
constraint satisfaction problem looks
like what we can do is we can now just
define different kinds of constraints
and then we can solve totally different
kinds of problems so using the same
framework
so here we have a queen's constraint
and a queen's constraint is going to
between be between variables that are
integers and the domains that are
integers why is that
well uh we can actually think about
the
variables in this case being the
different potential
columns of the of that the queen could
be on so that can be like columns a
through h on this board or we just use
integers so and you know in computing we
usually start counting at zero right so
we can also think about it as columns
zero through seven
and the same thing for the rows right we
can think about these as being rows zero
through seven or i might have actually
done one through eight in the code i
need to remind myself i did one through
eight so one through eight can be the
columns and one through eight can be the
rows
so
the csp then is going to then end up
associating each of the queens on
different columns and by the way we know
all the queens have to be on different
columns right because if any of the
queens were on the same columns they
would be attacking each other so we know
right off the bat it's like a little
trick that we have to put every queen on
a separate column right but then what we
don't know is which row to put them all
in once we've already put all of them
into separate columns so
knowing that all these different queens
are on different columns how do we
figure out the right row well again we
can just have our csp do a backtracking
search to solve that
so we've set up all the columns as our
variables we've set up the different
possible rows as our domains and then we
just implement a csp that has our a
constraint satisfaction problem that has
columns for the variables rows for the
domains really straightforward um but
then we have to add in the constraint
and this time you'll notice it's a
different kind of constraint so in the
map coloring problem that we looked at
before the constraint was always between
two different
locations on the map two different
regions of australia
now this problem the constraint is
actually between all of the different
variables at once right the constraint
is actually that we have to look at
every queen at the same time because
we're not just looking at two at a time
it's it's good if two of them are not
attacking each other but we want each of
them to not be attacking
all the other queens
so it's a different kind of constraint
here
it's a constraint where we're looking at
actually a list perhaps of all the
different potential queens
so how do we satisfy that constraint how
do we satisfy a constraint between all
of the possible different queens
i don't think there's some other
problems i want to cover so i don't
think we have to go through this in a
huge amount of detail but i'll go
through it in a little bit
um we look at the the column and the row
of each queen and so you can think about
this as the first queen so this is like
queen one column queen one row is what i
meant by the q1c the q1r here
then we look at each of the other queens
and so i call the other queens like q2c
is queen two column and queen two row so
we're going to end up looking at q1c and
q1r for one queen and then q2c and q2r
is going to be each of the other queens
so we have a total of eight queens right
so
uh the first queen is going to be
always q1c and q1r and then the other
seven queens are going to one at a time
be q2c and q2r having q1c and q1r
together with q2c and q2 are we can then
just compare them again this is like in
the australian map coloring problem it's
a simple check we just need to check
they're not the same right if they are
the same that's not good that means we
have not solved the problem if we have
two queens on the same row obviously we
haven't solved the problem the other
check here is for diagonals and using
absolute values here is just a quick way
of checking if the two are on the same
diagonal so in other words here we're
checking are these two queens on the
same row they're on the same row that's
not good we didn't solve the problem and
then in the second one we're just
checking are these two queens on the
same diagonal if they're on the same
diagonal we also did not solve the
problem however if they're not on the
same row and they're not on the same
diagonal and then we've gotten through
comparing this queen to all the other
queens then we've successfully solved
the problem and that means that we
return true so again it's a simple
comparison and the machinery for doing
all the searching was already
implemented by backtracking search back
in the constraint satisfaction problem
so here we can
do a totally different kind of problem
and solve it using the same framework so
let me try running this
and we will see what we get now this
might look a little cryptic but what
this is here is this is each
queen at some potential column with the
row that it should be on to solve the
problem so we solved here that queen
the queen on column one should be on row
one the queen on column two should be on
row five the queen on column three
should be on row eight and if we
followed all these and put them on the
chessboard they would not be attacking
one another and we would get a position
that looks like our final diagram here
which is having all the queens on
places where they're not attacking any
other queens so i hope you see that at
least in my mind this is quite a
different kind of problem than the
australian map coloring problem but
because we're able to break it down into
variables domains and constraints
we can solve it using the same generic
framework
here's a problem that everyone i'm sure
is familiar with this is a word search
so in this problem we have different
words that we want to put in a grid of
letters
and we want to make it so that the words
are legally within the grid of letters
without necessarily uh
overriding one another for lack of a
better word right so they need to safely
all be able to fit in there successfully
so how can we fit different size words
all into this grid is basically the the
challenge of the word search problem now
this one's a little bit more involved
and so i think i'm going to go through
the general outline of it and how it
uses the constraint satisfaction problem
framework
but
i won't go through maybe the details of
how we constructed all of
every part of it
so
let me open that up sorry going to the
wrong chapter there word search is this
similar to linear programming
yes linear programming can be thought of
as
a more advanced technique than this
generalized backtracking search to solve
constraint satisfaction problems but
yeah in linear programming you also have
constraints between variables usually
they're logic constraints between
variables and so there's a there's a
very significant overlap between
constraint satisfaction problems and
linear programming it's it's a great
great question
so
to figure out a word search in this case
we have a few different helper classes
we have a grid location that's like a
location
on the on the word search grid somewhere
a row and a column
we also have a grid and a grid is just
going to be
a
two dimension what in other programming
languages we call a two-dimensional uh
array but in python we call it a list of
lists so a list of lists of strings
where each string is really just going
to be a letter so i could maybe use a
character or something like that but
it's really just a single letter
somewhere on the grid
so having a grid of letters having
locations on the grid then we start to
have these methods for constructing a
grid and again i won't go into all of
these in a huge amount of detail but
what this is basically doing is
generating a random grid by using the
some built-in nice stuff from the python
standard library
and this is just displaying a grid it's
just printing it all out
then we get to the parts that are
actually related to a constraint
satisfaction problem
so generate domain
generate domain is going to go and
figure out for one potential variable
and i should have said what is a
variable in this well let me have you
think about that for a second as i go
back to the problem here what is
actually one of our variables what do
you think
a variable would be one of the words
that we want to put on the grid so in
this case we're putting names on so like
sarah would be a variable matthew would
be a variable the domains
are all of the potential places that we
could put that variable on the grid
so for example
it depends if we start counting from the
bottom or from the top here but let's
say we started counting from the top
going down and from the top going to
from the left going to the right
so we could say that matthew was
actually placed at location
like
1 one if we start counting at zero right
um and then each of his individual
letters was placed in some additional
locations as well that's really the
domain is like where are the potential
places that we could put a word in the
grid so again this is like a different
kind of problem right than the eight
queens problem or the australian map
coloring problem but you'll see we're
able to solve it using the same
framework
okay
so i won't again i won't go into all the
details here because i do want to get to
one more problem after this but generate
domain looks through the entire grid and
tries to find locations that it could
potentially put one of those words and
it gathers together all those different
locations that words can go and those
cumulative locations are the potential
domains for each of the variables so
those are the places that we could put
uh those those words those are the
places we could put the words that's the
domain
and then what is a constraint in this
case
a constraint
is going to be a check to make sure
that we're not putting words on top of
each other right i don't want to put up
the word for the first letter for
matthew is an m right and the first
letter for sarah is an s right
if i overwrite the m with an s
then i actually do not successfully
construct a word search problem right so
i need to make sure that i'm not
overwriting one letter with another
letter from a different word
and so actually that's pretty simple
here all i'm doing here is again just
checking that we don't have any of them
on the same location and how do i do
that well this is a convenient trick
that you use in programming a lot is if
you want to eliminate duplicates you can
just change over from
a
a list to a set or if i was in another
programming language i'd be saying i'm
going from an array to a set anytime you
go from
a list to a set or in another
programming language an array to a set
you're going to eliminate duplicates
because by definition sets are not
allowed to have duplicates of the same
value
so
what we end up with in the end is we end
up with
just the the non-duplicated
locations
for some assignments
and we check
is that the same number
of locations as we originally had in the
assignment
if that's true that after eliminating
duplicates we still had the same number
that would mean that we didn't actually
have any overlaps so i hope you see here
how the converting things to a set is
really helping us check for duplicates
and then by checking for duplicates
we're actually checking that nothing is
overlapping or overwriting one another
um so
i i hope that you can kind of see how
that fits together but look how compact
that is right just two lines of code and
we've checked that we don't have any
overlapping locations look how simple
word search constraint is right this is
where we're overriding again something
from
the original csp problem that we looked
at at the beginning of the stream right
and the types again it's a generic type
and i know not everyone loves the type
hints but let me just mention how the
type hints fit in here we're saying that
the variables in this problem are
strings and remember those are again the
words so in our example i'll open up the
example again that's like matthew or
mary or sarah those are all strings
right and then the places that matthew
can go or the places that mary or sarah
can go those are grid locations and we
looked at the grid location class
earlier and so the cumulative places
that they can go is a list of grid
locations and so a list of grid
locations is what makes up the
domain for each of those variables
okay
so we defined our word search
constraints uh we defined what what the
actual variables are and in this case i
just use those those variables matthew
joe mary sarah sally there's just
strings
we define what the domains are we use
that method generate domain to figure
out all the potential different places
that the um
that the each of the words can go
and then we generated a csp just as we
did before and again the csp class
doesn't change it's the same exact class
for solving all these different kinds of
problems and we added in a word search
constraints to make sure that none of
the individual words ends up overlapping
or overwriting one another and then we
just run a backtracking search
and it's that simple if we were
successful
then we're good and we can go printing
out the uh the final grid
if we were not successful
then we it turns out that probably we
had too many words or we had some words
that were so long that they couldn't fit
within the grid with other words and so
they ended up having to overwrite each
other and so we couldn't find a way to
put them all in but let's try running it
here
and of course i chose an example where i
knew we could solve it but but here you
see a solution at the bottom here where
we've managed to fit all the different
words that we wanted to fit um in here
somehow i see matthews up here here's
sarah i think joe is upside down here
and there's probably some more in the
other well they must be the other ones
must be in there as well
anyway okay so that's another totally
different kind of problem but because we
could still define it using variables
domains and constraints we could still
solve it the same way using a
backtracking search and a constraint
satisfaction problem framework
but our last kind of problem is another
classic problem it's called send plus
more equals money
and maybe you tried to do this some
point in a
math class when you were growing up
maybe in elementary school or middle
school probably middle school
you tried to solve this problem at some
point it's a crypt arithmetic problem
and what that means is we have
characters that are supposed to
represent digits and so let me make this
even bigger because i i it's probably a
little small for you on the screen so
we have send plus more and each of these
letters is supposed to represent a
different digit zero through nine so for
example maybe d is supposed to be four
hypothetically or maybe e is supposed to
be seven then any time that we see that
same letter we expect the same digit to
be able to fill in to make the problem
and its solution true so anytime we see
an e we expect there to be a 7. so if
there was going to be a 7 here we expect
there to also be a 7 here and also a 7
here
if we can find digits that can fit in
for each of the letters
then we can successfully solve the
problem so before i should go and show
you the code i want you to be thinking
about this right now
what is the variables here what is the
domains
and what are the potential constraints
or the constraints between all of these
there might just i'll give you a hint
there might just be one constraint in
this case although you could i could
think of a way you could formulate it
with multiple constraints but there's
one really obvious constraint here but
what do you think the variables are what
do you think the domains are
and what do you think the constraint is
i'll take away the the suspense the
variables could potentially be
all the different letters
okay so each of the individual letters
could be our variables
the domains would be the digits that can
try to fit in for each of those letters
so each of the letters could potentially
be the letters 0 through 9 we don't know
what the right answer is yet but that's
what they potentially could be to solve
the problem so notice the constraints by
the way we don't excuse me in the
variables we don't duplicate our letters
right because even though the e ends up
being in the problem three times right
there's only one letter e that we're
trying to solve for even though we see
the letter e three times there's only
one value that we're trying to find for
letter e because it's going to be the
same value in every location right
okay
so uh let me just go back now to
to the code
so we have our domain
we have our variables
last part as you've seen the pattern now
right is we always have to have a
constraint
so
the constraint in this case the send
more money constraint is really really
straightforward in fact it might be our
most straightforward constraint other
than the australian map coloring problem
that we did earlier
it's really straightforward because the
problem spells out the constraint for
you the constraint is that whatever
values we assigned for the letters this
equation has to be true
send plus more has to equal money right
that is the constraint so what do we do
let's just do a little bit of arithmetic
for whatever letters we've assigned what
excuse me whatever digits we've assigned
to the letters
let's just do the arithmetic and see if
they solve the problem and that would
that would be a solution our constraint
so let's see here
looking at satisfied the first thing
we'll check is have we actually tried
assigning some value to every letter so
until we've actually tried giving every
letter a value there's no point in
actually doing the arithmetic right
because if i don't have a value i can't
there's nothing for me to add up so i
need to actually have values but once i
have
all the different potential values let's
see what i can do well i can actually
construct the equation here how can i
construct the equation well look at
where each of these lo these items is
right if this was a um
if this was just a number here right
this would be the the d would be in the
ones place the n would be in the tens
place the e would be in the hundreds
place and the s would be in the
thousands place
right
and so what i can do is i can just
multiply each of the potential digits
by its
placement numerically
and i will end up getting the
the number that that together they
represent
so i end up calculating what send
represents i end up calculating what
more represents and i end up calculating
what money represents using the domain
values that have filled in for the
variables that are represented by the
letters
then i just check is send plus more
equal equal to money
if they are
this means that
we actually have solved the seven plus
more equals money problem
how easy was that right it was so
similar to some of these other
constraint satisfaction problems that
we've done and yet it's so different
it's so different in that when you look
at this problem
right when i look at this problem
i don't see a map i don't see the
australian map coloring problem
so you have to realize
what are variables what are domains and
how can they be constrained between each
other but there's a huge wide variety of
problems that can actually be solved
this way anyway let's try uh running
this and try
seeing if we have a solution of course i
know we do and if it doesn't run right
now and doesn't give us a solution
that's really bad
because it's in the book right so anyway
so here's a potential solution so if you
go and fill this in you'll see that this
actually ends up being send plus more
equals money and i'll show you that i
think i have of course i would have put
this in the book
um
it's uh after the end here
the solution here i know what i should
have done this is a good thing for the
second edition of the book i should have
lined up the numbers again here right i
should have lined up each of the numbers
again and spelled out to prove to you
that they actually
solve for one another
but anyway if you line up the digits and
you put them in the right places now
you'll see it does add up send plus more
does equal money
um
anyway so we made it through four
different constraint satisfaction
problems and the key thing i wanted to
take away is that we were able to use
the same backtracking search and the
same very simple framework for
setting up a constraint satisfaction
problem to solve all of them i imagine
in your software development tasks
whether you're a professional software
developer or hobbyist software developer
you come across problems that could be
solved using this framework i'm not
saying that the version that we
implemented here is the most efficient
way to solve these problems it's not
necessarily and there's other extensions
to constraint satisfaction problems that
we could talk about but probably beyond
the scope of today things like
rearranging the order that we look at
the constraints in to go through them as
efficiently as possible or going through
the variables that have the most
constraints put on them first or the
least constraints put on them first that
kind of ordering can actually make us go
through the potential solutions more
quickly and then there's also a whole
different way not using a backtracking
search but using a totally different
method that's way beyond our scope today
called forward checking that can
sometimes be more efficient in trying to
solve one of these problems if you want
now my book is a book that gives you
a
really broad overview of different kinds
of problems it's not a deep book in the
sense that i'm not going to explain to
you every every single different way to
solve a constraint satisfaction problem
or every way to make it more efficient
i'm going to just introduce you to the
idea of a constraint satisfaction
problem show you a real way of solving
them as we did here
and then if you want to go further of
course there's whole books on the
subject one i would recommend is
artificial intelligence a modern
approach covers constraint satisfaction
problems in chapter six of that book so
if you want to go in a lot of depth into
this chapter six of that book is great
but if you just want to get the first
introduction chapter three of my book is
a great first introduction and you can
also manning is offering that for free
right now
through
live books on the website and we also
have an article that is linked to from
the constraint satisfaction excuse me
from the class computer science problems
and python page that goes through this
as well and kind of walks you through
the code and all the code i went on here
today is on my github repository for the
book so if my my github username is
davecom i should have put a link in
somewhere um i can do that in the chat
later but um you can go on my repository
davecom d-a-v-e-c-o-m find class
computer science problems in python
repository and you'll find all this code
on there as well